- Hey guys, it's Justine!
And I have a problem and
I'm here to talk about it.
I was back home visiting with family
not too long ago
and that's about the
time Dr. Mario came out.
And since then,
I had some free time, so I thought:
'OK, I'm going to allow myself to play
this mobile game' thinking
'this isn't going to be dangerous.
It'll be fine, I'll just
kill some time this week
and then I can go back to my life.'
And I could not be more wrong,
because I wake up I'm
thinking about this game
I go to sleep, I'm
thinking about this game.
Actually, I play it before bed
and I play as soon as I wake up.
I can't stop! It is so much fun!
So, I just wanted to show you guys
a little bit of gameplay and then...
Jenna actually tried to have an um...
a little intervention with me so
you'll see that here in a minute.
But I'm just gonna go
through and play a stage
and just show you what the game's about
if you haven't played it yet
and this is not sponsored because I've
actually spent my actual
real money on this game
and probably spent way too much.
I'm not proud of it.
So I'm currently on level 128.
Let's just go through, play this level,
and I'll show you guys what
this game is all about.
I always like to put
something underneath of it
because I need just a
little bit of leverage.
(game noises)
All of those little guys
floating to the top.
All right well...
not much I can do about that one.
I'm not enjoying this map very much.
This is...
This is not a fun one.
Here I am talking this game up
and then I'm playing this difficult level.
Let's get you out of there.
Let's get you.
Get you.
This game is so silly.
I love it so much!
Great.
Whole squad is unlocked.
They are ready.
That was a mistake!
Did not mean to do that!
I'm not happy about it.
This is a bit of a predicament here.
This is not my best
game guys I'm really...
pretty upset about it.
Yesss!
That could not have been more perfect
to be honest with you.
This is working out great...except...
Okay, I'm gonna have to use the hammer
just for this last one.
Because that's what I had to do.
Okay.
We just cleared a level!
There's also versus and the ranked play
and I am stuck at tier four right now.
Like, I have to get to tier five
but it's 1600+ points
and I keep dying so much.
But once you get around like 1300
everyone gets really, really good.
So, I'm gonna play a match here and hope
I can get to 1600 within a week.
Cause everyone's so good.
Okay. Are you ready?
Focus! Focus up!
This is where you have to go super quick.
No mistakes...could be made.
Oh my gosh, that was a
mistake, that was mistake,
that was a mistake!
I didn't mean to do it!
Oh my gosh! Oh my gosh!
This is terrible! This is
terrible! This is terrible!
This is terrible!
This is awful! Absolutely terrible!
Oh my gosh!
It's okay, it's okay,
it's okay, I can recover.
I can recover, I can recover,
I can do anything.
I can do anything, I'm a champion.
(muttering)
Oh my god, okay.
They are doing so well.
They are doing very well.
I won! I won! I won! I won!
Okay, oh my gosh!
Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes! Yes!
So, that's what I've
been doing with my time.
- We don't need any more reasons
for you to play the game.
The past week, all she's been doing
is playing "Dr. Mario World" and
I'm genuinely concerned about her health.
Like, was is it, did you buy it?
How much money have
you spent on this game?
Have you been working?
Like, I'm worried! I'm
genuinely worried about it.
Has mommy been taking care of you?
- (Justine) Don't touch me! Don't touch--
- (Jenna) Like, you have a pro--
- (Justine) You just took
a screenshot! Stop it!
I'm playing a versus game!
- (Jenna) You have a problem!
- (Justine) Give me that! Give me that!
I will put you to sleep!
Don't make me do it! Don't make me do it!
You wanna go to sleep?
- (Justine) Give me the phone!
(play fighting)
- Don't touch me!
- Oh, we're done here now? Okay.
- (Off camera Justine)
Like, I honestly think
that I have a future here.
You do realize that there
are Fortnite tournaments
for like 3 million dollars.
I--
- You're not playing Fortnite!
You're playing Dr. Mario-something.
- "Dr. Mario World", get it right.
- (Justine) Can I show you how good I am?
- (Jenna) Fine.
- (Jenna) Well, I don't even
know what the game is, I--
- (Justine) Here's the
thing: I have to be sitting--
I have to have it at a special angle.
- Oh! A special angle.
Come on, Matty, let's go play.
- (off-screen Jenna) I
just don't understand--
- (Justine) Promise me
you're not gonna touch it
because this will hurt my rank.
Promise me--
- (off-screen Jenna) Okay,
I'm not gonna touch it!
- So basically I'm racing...against...
- (Jenna) Can you see what they're doing?
(Jenna) Are you winning?
- (Justine) I don't
know yet I can't think.
- (Jenna) Oh...
- (Justine) They froze me.
- (Jenna) I don't--
- (Justine) Shoot, shoot, shoot!
I messed up! I messed up! Oh God!
- (Jenna) Matty's excited.
- (Justine) Shh, shh. I'm
focusing, I'm focusing.
- (Jenna) You can't talk and--
- (Justine) This takes a lot of focus.
- (Jenna) Can you see
what their ranking is?
(Jenna) Oh, I'm not
allowed to speak, right?
(Jenna) This is fun for everyone.
- (Justine) If I lose
this, I'm going to be
so embarrassed because
everyone's watching me now.
- (off-screen Jenna)
Yeah, the whole internet.
- (Jenna) Did you just match the colors?
(muttering)
- (Jenna) That's...that's fun.
- (Jenna) Look, I'm on
level 2000 in (inaudible).
Like I get it.
- (Justine) Oh shoot, I
just messed up! Oh my god!
One mistake...
it can really ruin you.
- (Jenna) Much like life, people.
That's also good life advice.
- (Justine) They are doing so well.
(Justine) They are doing so well.
(Justine) They're doing so well!
- (Jenna) Well, why aren't you?
- (Justine) I'm trying my hardest
but they're doing very well.
- (off-screen Jenna) Do
you think they spent $40
on the game or...
- (Justine) Did I win?
Did I win? Hold on...
(Justine) I won! I won! I won!
I'm sweating so bad like
you don't understand.
- (Justine) Even Matty's
been playing Dr. Mario
because he been watching
me play it so much.
Here you go Matty, ready?
(Justine) Dr. Mario time!
- (Jenna) Not you too...
(Jenna) Oh my gosh...
- (Justine) Sit.
- (Jenna) I've lost you both.
- (Justine) Dr. Mario time.
(Justine) Yes, that's my boy.
(Justine) That's my boy, come
on, get those viruses, Matty!
- (Jenna) He's a higher level than you.
(Jenna) I've lost them
all to "Dr. Mario World".
- (Justine) Just like mommy.
- (Jenna) Guess I'll download it.
(music gets louder)